now we've got to be honest with you
there are some things about your fairy
tale that just don't add up we know you
do everything you can to help your
friends and save your kingdom but
sometimes you do the impossible without
offering valid explanations it's not
just you though
everyone in auradon seems to march to
the beat of their own drum now we're
hoping you can clear up some questions
we have about the three descendants
films Kenny Ortega did a great job
directing the three descendants movies
but there are some potholes that we just
can't ignore watch until the end to find
out how audrey's evil really could have
been avoided Dizzy's royal invitation
dizzy Tremaine is one of a kind she's
talented trendy and super sweet which is
why she was basically made for auradon
Evie saw Dizzy's potential from a mile
away and asked King Ben to invite her to
auradon prep at the end of descendants -
we'd love you to join us - auradon prep
will you come sign king bed so we were
more than a little confused when she
received a second invitation at the
beginning of d3 what made things even
more confusing was that dizzy seemed
surprised when Evie picked her
Maleficent crosses the barrier the Isle
of the Lost
is a simple place where nothing really
happens there's no Wi-Fi magic or
Netflix so things can get a little
boring the barrier surrounding the Isle
is designed to keep magic out it
immediately disables magic and we saw
proof of this when old hag mal crossed
the barrier and became young again
[Music]
so why didn't my LIF isn't the lizard
shut her in phibian skin when mal
brought her back to the island
descendants to keep watching to find out
about another barrier related plothole
this meet wins if there's one thing we
love about the descendants franchise
it's how we get to meet the descendants
of some of our favorite Disney heroes
and villains we were so excited to meet
the new decays especially since they
were going to play a huge part in the
three-pole but before we knew it the
movie was over and we hardly got to see
sneeze twin boys squeaky and squirmy in
action the boys spent most of the movie
asleep and uttered all but two lines we
would have loved to see more of the Nuvi
kaze do what you gotta do
we loved Hades and mouths duet but some
of the lyrics just didn't make sense
mal sings about her father not being
there she says guess you don't have a
phone you never called to say I miss you
but this line fell flat considering the
people of the Isles don't have any
reception according to descendants wiki
Wi-Fi and cell phone signals don't work
on the aisle fairy godmother had to make
a special exception for the BK's to call
home in d2 so Hades couldn't have called
mal even if he wanted to the Evil
Queen's daughter the Evil Queen might be
a danger to everyone but Evie is proud
to call her mom much like Maleficent the
Evil Queen has some powers of her own
magic and witchcraft are her Forte's and
she most definitely passed her powers
down to EB but for some reason Evie
doesn't appear to have any powers in the
decom movies mal in houma combined their
powers to save auradon but couldn't have
Evie done the very same thing dude the
dog crosses the barrier mal and her
friends were able to defeat Emma and her
pirates in descendants - thanks - dude
the dog uma treated then for the wand
after mal proved it was authentic
but in the end it was all a trick
but please why is it that dude was able
to talk after crossing the barrier
chimney has fell have been broken the
second his paws touch down on the Isle
of the Lost
without this major plot hole now would
have never convinced umma that the wand
was the real deal
why did haiti steal mouse powers the
ants knew ahead of time that Hades would
turn out to be Mel's dad so most of us
were confused when we saw him draining
mouse powers in the trailers Hades hit
now with a beam of blue magic right in
the chest and later on mal told her
friends that he was draining her powers
however Mouse powers never took a hit at
first we figured out Hades didn't know
that mal was his daughter but that just
wasn't the case so why did he drain her
powers and what did he do with them
motorcycling grandma Audrey turns mal
into an old hag in descendants 3 and
melon our gang rushed to the Isle to
retrieve Hades ember now can barely move
in her old woman's body
she's crouched down and needs help to
walk but next thing we know mal is
wearing a tight leather outfit and
riding her purple bike clearly old hag
mal was in no shape to bike across the
water
the missing apples we loved Audrey solo
queen of mean but we couldn't help but
notice a case of the vanishing apples
during her solo
Audrey Knox a basket of apples to the
floor but when the scene cuts back
they're nowhere to be found
museum security is it just us or does
the museum security guard deserve the
boot he was taking a nap despite uma
being on the loose and Audrey snuck
right by him if we read on had better
security Audrey would have never turned
evil in descendants 3 and
it's a wrap did you notice any other
plot holes in the descendants franchise
sound off in the comments subscribe to
our channel and give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll see
you next time on the themes
[Music]